URS HOLZLE: Thank you.
Way too much credit, Diane,
but welcome to Horizon.
And as Diane
mentioned, we've been
building a hyperscale cloud and
running it for quite a while.
And it has over
eight applications
powered by this cloud with
more than a billion users--
Seach, Maps, YouTube,
and so on and so on.
And as Diane mentioned,
the eighth one
is actually TCP Google
Cloud Platform itself.
So every day, Google Cloud
Platform applications--
not by Google, by
our customers-- touch
over a billion
different IP addresses
worldwide every single day.
So it's really an
incredible scale.
And that scale requires
an incredible investment.
I'm very proud that the 10-plus
years of investment-- not just
money but really expertise,
very hard work by a very
large team-- is being
recognized today.
And I want to start
off by just showing you
how we're different from
other clouds in a few ways.
So the first one Diane
already mentioned a little bit
is our network.
It's probably one of our
biggest areas of investment.
We have hundreds of thousands
of miles of fiber that we own.
The largest, fastest, highest
capacity submarine cable
in the world, for example,
was built by Google.
And generally
speaking, you can reach
with this private backbone
pretty much any place on Earth.
That really means
pretty much any place.
So, for example, we have
physical infrastructure
in Bhutan.
If you don't know where
it is, look it up.
Really wonderful country.
Next, we also have operated
at scale for a very long time.
And if you operate
at our scale, you
realize that efficiency and
performance is important.
And so we had lots
of time and lots
of expertise to really
do that and it shows.
Another TCP first
is VM migration.
Just because we do
maintenance or just
because we have
to do an upgrade,
you shouldn't need
to do anything.
So on TCP, despite us
upgrading things all the time,
your workload just
keeps running.
And of course, we provide
great value-- thank you,
Lydia-- on up to 59% less
for the same workload
at great performance.
And what's more important, we
put the cloud back in cloud
because with per minute
billing, custom VM
types, automatic
discounts, no worrying
about reserved instances
or long-term contracts,
you pay as you go.
That's what cloud
was invented for.
And so with our
approach to pricing--
our user-friendly
we're just much easier
to do business with.
So of course, we're
improving this product.
Diane talked a little
bit about the launches.
I want to highlight
just a few things that
launched in the past few weeks.
One was our SQL service V2.
It's the highest throughput
SQL service on any cloud.
Automated storage
sizing for SQL.
So you never run out of storage
space for your database,
because we grow it
automatically for you.
Weather data for BigQuery
if you want to correlate
your data with weather.
New machine, learning APIs.
VM rightsizing recommendations
to save you money.
Lower pricing for
preemptable VMs.
Another first-- resizing
persistent disks
without downtime while
your VM keeps running.
So it's just a few
of the improvements
that we launched in just
the last four to six weeks.
Now, we see incredible demand
from pretty much anywhere
in the world.
And to make sure that all users
have a cloud next to them,
we're going to roll out new
regions at a rapid pace.
In the UK, in
Germany, in Finland,
and in India, and Singapore,
and Australia, and Brazil.
And the last country,
northern Virginia.
And so we're actually
going to-- and this
is on top of Oregon, which
we rolled out earlier.
Japan is coming next
week and next month.
And starting in
2017, we're going
to roll out roughly one
new region per month,
and we're going to keep up
that pace for quite a while.
So this is just the first
wave of our expansion.
You're going to hear more about
the next wave in the coming
months.
All of these regions are
going to be multi-zone,
so you can run high
availability applications
in a single region.
And they're going to be
connected by the Google Cloud
Network-- the largest private
backbone in the world.
So your connectivity is going
to be fast no matter where
you are and no matter where your
users are because you can reach
them using the same connectivity
that Google reaches that user.
All right, now, I
told you that we're
building a different cloud.
And I want to tell
you a little bit more,
but to do that, let
me go a little bit
about the history of clouds.
So cloud in many ways
started about 20 years ago
with colocation.
Colocation let you rent
data center space instead
of having to worry
about investing
building, maintaining,
running a data center.
So that was great.
And pretty soon
afterwards, it went really
to the second wave
of cloud, where
all of this infrastructure
was virtualized.
So you had the same components--
servers, disks, networks,
whatever, load balancers--
but now they're
virtual, not physical.
And that's great because what
used to be a purchase order now
becomes an API
call and, poof, you
have a new machine or a
new disk or a new whatever.
And that really transformed
how people do IT.
It's a very, very deep impact.
But it maintained the same
structure of the data center.
Everything is
virtual now, but you
deal with the same components,
and it's just as hard
to put them together
and to maintain them
and to actually
keep things running.
So that forces the
user to still focus
a lot of their effort
on the wrong things.
Do I have enough servers?
Do they have the right type?
Did I purchase too much
or maybe too little?
Do I need to upgrade my OS?
Do I have a security alert?
All of these things
your staff is
forced to pay attention
to instead of writing
new applications,
creating value, having
innovative applications.
And innovative
applications is ultimately
how businesses win,
how they get new users,
how they get new
markets, how they
make their employees happy.
So until about 10 years
ago, we were actually
in that same boat.
Our internal infrastructure
looked about like that,
and we were struggling
with all of that.
And we realized that we
can't really maintain
our pace of innovation.
We can't really be Google
if we don't get out
of this complexity.
So about 10 years
ago, we really started
to redo our infrastructure.
We started with a
container-based model,
moving away from machines,
and with automated services
and scalable data.
And that lets our developers
enjoy unprecedented scale,
reliability, security
without worrying
that much about the
infrastructure behind it.
And this is what we have
brought to Google Cloud Platform
and that many of you
benefit from today.
Let me just give
you a few examples.
For example, App Engine--
Google App Engine--
lets you write an app.
You never have to
worry about servers.
You never have to worry
about operating systems.
You don't even have to
worry about regions,
zone outages, nothing.
You can have an
ambitious application,
you can run it for a year,
and you can have literally--
and I mean literally-- zero
hours on administration.
Or take another
example, BigQuery,
our analytic solution, there is
no provisioning of an analytics
cluster.
There's no maintenance.
There's no sizing.
There's no upgrading.
Just bring your data
and start querying.
Or Container Engine runs
your Kubernetes containers
without you having to
really administer anything.
Or even for conventional
things like Hadoop clusters,
you can be up and
running in 90 seconds,
have your Hadoop cluster,
zero administration.
So no ops is really a big step.
And the third wave
of computing I think
needs to focus on making all of
the power of cloud accessible
without you worrying about
the details behind it.
Now, Google was founded
with an ambitious mission--
organize all the
world's information.
And that obviously required
us to become experts
at handling lots of data.
Just for Search.
For Search, we have
to store and index
and serve a private
copy of the entire web.
And we've been doing
that for 15 years.
We've had our first
trillion-line log analysis
running sometime
in the early 2000s.
So we've been dealing with
big data for a long time,
and that forced us
to really pioneer
many of the tools and
techniques that are used today
in big data.
And we're a
data-driven business.
And so this wasn't just
about infrastructure,
this was about
creating tools that
lets many Google employees
analyze and understand
the data that we have.
So let me talk a little
bit more about that,
because externally in
Google Cloud Platform,
we took these internal tools
and made them available to you.
And they were really making a
big impact to our customers.
The key tool is BigQuery.
BigQuery is our
analytic solution.
And it lets you take pretty much
an unlimited amount of data--
and I mean that literally--
and run SQL queries against it
and get results in seconds.
Don't have to worry about
scalability or maintenance
or anything-- no provisioning,
no maintenance, zero ops.
So it's really been a
game changer for many.
And I'm very excited
today to announce
that we have a major
new version of BigQuery
available-- BigQuery
for Enterprise.
One of the key changes in
BigQuery for Enterprise
is that you can
now update tables.
So that turns it from
an analytic solution
into a full data warehouse.
So BigQuery Enterprise comes
with many very nice features.
I can mention just a few.
I already mentioned
support for DML.
So you can do updates,
deletes on your data.
It supports SQL, so
all of your tools
or pretty much all of
your tools will work out
of the box with
BigQuery Enterprise.
Heavy users can
get flat pricing,
a predictable bill every month.
I'll talk more about
that afterwards.
And of course, like
all of our services,
you have identity
and access management
that gives you security and
compliance for your data
and access to your data.
We have lots of other features I
can't talk about-- for example,
just like in Google
Docs, we tried
to make collaboration easy.
So sharing queries is as
easy as sharing a link.
And of course, being from
Google, it's extremely fast.
We asked a third party
to run some benchmarks
based on the industry
standard TCPH benchmarks.
Here's a graph that shows
when multiple users run
TCPH query number
10-- no, number 22
on 10 terabytes of data.
Sorry.
So when you have a few
users, both systems
are reasonably fast.
But as you increased
usage, of the power
and the automatic scalability of
BigQuery really starts to show.
And at 32 users,
it's 29 times faster
because BigQuery can scale
automatically for you.
And it scales independently
of the data size.
So you get just the
right performance
at a very attractive price.
Let me actually
elaborate on that.
So it is high
performance does not
come at the penalty of
paying through your nose.
It's not just easier to use,
it's also cheaper to use.
Now how is that?
Here's another comparison.
This assumes that
you have a data
warehouse that grows over time.
And so you get not just
the higher performance
that you just saw, but you
get low predictable cost.
Because BigQuery only uses
resources when you are actually
running queries.
So let me give you an analogy.
It's a little bit
like a light switch.
So with Amazon Redshift,
you have to pick a room size
and you have to pick the number
of light bulbs in that room.
And then you have to
turn it, on and you
have to leave it turned
on for the entire month
whether you're in
the room or not.
And no surprise, your bill
at the end of the month
is going to be
pretty substantial.
In comparison, BigQuery
is a little bit more
like a motion
sensor light switch.
So the light goes on when
you enter the room, goes off
when you leave it.
Magically, the room is
just always well-lit
and the right size.
And so no wonder,
your bill can be lower
at the end of the month.
So you get this scalability
and the zero administration
at a much lower price
than comparable solutions.
So with that, it's
really pretty easy
to choose your cloud data
warehouse because really
no other data
warehouse offers you
a combination of
these functionalities
and the choice
between pay as you go,
which is ideal for light
users, and fixed pricing, which
is ideal for heavy users.
So that much about analytics--
and obviously, analytics
is really, really
important, because it
lets you take your data
and derive value from it.
But often, machine
learning can actually
derive even bigger value
from that same data.
To give an example,
just a few months ago,
we have applied machine
learning to our own data centers
and to the controls of the
cooling system of that data
center.
We were able to save up to 40%
of cooling energy in our data
centers by applying
machine learning.
So it's really terrific.
The problem is that
machine learning
has a high hurdle to adoption.
You need a lot of expertise
and a lot of compute
to actually make
it work for you.
And our goal is to change that.
Our goal is to democratize
machine learning
and really make it possible
for everyone to use it.
And how we do that I'll show
you in the next few minutes.
The key to it is cloud
machine learning,
and easiest way to use
cloud machine learning
is to use complete solutions.
So we launched a strong set
of machine learning APIs that
solve common problems for you.
For example, here's
a sound file.
Tell me what's spoken
in that sound file.
These are trained
machine learning
models-- trained by
us, maintained by us,
fully come as a service.
Basically, bring your
data and get knowledge,
insight out of it.
These have been launched
throughout the year
and have actually been some
of our most popular APIs ever.
So usage is skyrocketing.
But on top of having these
canned solutions that
solve common problems,
you also need
to be able to build
your own solution.
And for that, we created
Cloud Machine Learning.
It went alpha early this
year, and today, I'm
excited to announce that it's
now available to everyone
as Cloud Machine Learning beta.
It comes with a number
of great features.
First, should be
no surprise by now
that it is a no ops
machine learning solution.
So you don't have
to create a training
cluster or a prediction
cluster or choose machine size
or whatever.
You just focus on your problem.
And once you have your
machine learning model,
you just install it and
we autoscale it for you
to arbitrary demand.
So zero ops to run
and train your models.
Of course, you get
performance as well.
So you can do training at scale.
You get the full power--
the parallelized computing--
of the Google Cloud.
And so model size is not
going to be a problem.
It comes with a nice UI as well.
You're going to
see that in a demo.
Data Lab is kind of
like a notebook that
lets you develop your
code but also document it
and share it very easily.
And you can also manage
your training runs,
your different versions.
You can connect to BigQuery
or to Google Cloud Storage.
So it's easy to build a
full solution, not just
a machine learning model.
And last but not least, we
have a very special feature
that we call Hypertune.
It's a little bit
esoteric, but when
you build a machine
learning model,
one of the most
important things is
to get the model roughly right.
But then, usually
today, that would
be followed by days
and weeks of tuning,
because this model has
a lot of parameters
and you need to find out which
settings actually maximize
the accuracy of your model.
And Google Cloud ML Hypertune
does that maximization for you.
So we try lots of versions
in the background,
and you can accomplish
in an hour what
today takes an expert days
or even weeks to get to.
And you'll see
that a little bit.
It's really an
incredible timesaver.
But rather than me
talking to slides,
let's actually see
that in action.
I'd like to invite Rob
Craft up to the stage,
and he's going to give you a
demo of a few different ways
how customers use
machine learning.
Rob, over to you.
ROB CRAFT: Thanks very much.
Good morning.
So is my mic on?
It is on, awesome.
So what you're looking at is
80,000 Creative Common images
that we put through
our Vision API service.
As I mentioned, this is
a fully trained model
based on a lot of
learnings we had
creating Google
Photos, which does
an amazing job about
understanding cognitively
what you are showing
it in pixel form.
So here, we mapped 80,000
worth, and I plugged it
into a nice pretty word cloud.
That gives you an idea
of how these things map
that make sense to people.
And then we have a couple
images to the side that shows
you a little bit of the power.
So the first is
the recognition--
and forgive me for the
analogy, but the internet
is powered with cats.
And here is a cat to prove it.
Urs has private islands
bought with cat money
I think at this point.
So there's two things
that are important here.
One is that we're
successfully labeling
on the side what the image is.
And as you might suppose,
close up, far away,
color of, long hair, short
hair, looking at camera,
not looking at camera-- you have
to have a pretty sophisticated
understanding of
visualization systems
to get this sort
of thing correct.
But you want to know how
correct it is because it
could be a business decision.
You never believe anyone
without data, of course,
if you're running a
successful business.
So on the side here, we're
giving you an indication
of how certain we are.
So we're 99% sure it's a cat.
And it's 83% sure it's
a domestic short hair.
We give you lots of other
information like the color
palette.
For those you with brand
sensitivity for colors
and textures and fields for
your advertising campaigns,
this matters a lot and
it's really hard to get.
And we offer a
lot of other data,
like is it
inappropriate content?
90% of the new data
arriving in your business
is unstructured data like this.
It's voice, it's audio,
it's in a language
that you don't speak.
It's directly from a customer.
It's about your
brand on the internet
that you can't find yourself.
Systems like that
it's drastically
change the capability to
understand how people are
talking about you, how you
would like to be talking,
how to be talked about.
And as well as what
imagery matters.
We also do it for the other
languages and capabilities.
So let me do one more and I'll
flip over to another demo.
This one is pretty exciting for
those of us that like sports.
On the surface, for
those of us from the US,
this is very obviously
a baseball stadium.
A computer can't
make that assumption,
so we start from scratch.
We don't believe
you when you label
this is a baseball stadium, for
example, because it turns out
people aren't always necessarily
truthful on the internet.
I know it's surprising,
but there we are.
So it's a stadium.
It's a team sport.
We're even picking up
some baseball equipment.
You see the little picture
in the background--
the guy holding a baseball
bat-- we picked up
that it's a baseball
bat, not just a stick.
And here is the part that
I'm especially proud of,
not only do we grab the
text on all the signage
in the background-- and we're
offering bounding boxes soon
so you can pick
what area the image
you want to look at--
but we identified out
of all the baseball
stadiums, this is Citi Field.
So that capability
applied to landmarks
using the power
of what we learned
from Maps and other systems
becomes available for you.
And to do one of these images
is literally six lines of code.
So this vastly changes
the world around
what machine
learning can provide
versus the work
you think you have
to do to get machine learning
benefits in your applications.
So we're done.
Everyone ready to do their
first neural network?
Let's do a neural network.
This will be fun.
So we're going to start
with something that
matters a lot for this room.
Let's predict
whether the S&P 500
is going to close up or down.
In this case,
we're going to take
50 years plus worth of data
across 3,200 stock tickers.
We're going to combine it
using some training information
across other pieces, pump
it through a neural network,
and out the other side is
going to come a prediction.
This identifies what a lot
of people in your businesses
are doing today or that you'll
be asked to do going forward,
which is create your own model.
So we're using the
Google Data Lab tool
that Urs mentioned a
little bit earlier.
It's a notebook
that has compile.
You can actually compile queries
and do visualizations natively
in the here.
An example of a visualization
of a data set is here.
You can see that it's
a little bit noisy,
so we're going to precondition
some data to clean it up.
Much tighter
distribution of data
sets, so we're going to
learn faster with our model.
And what does a model look like?
Well, in this case--
pardon the lingo drop,
but I need to show
that it's a real thing.
It's a feed four neural
network, four hidden layers,
1,024 nodes per layer.
We're doing rectified
linear [? units ?] between,
and then we have a
soft max regression.
A long way of saying this
is a reasonable demo.
It ain't production, so
please don't do trading
based on the numbers you're
going to see at the bottom.
I said it-- I am
not responsible.
So this is a prettier
picture for those of us
that forget everything
that I just said.
It's a reasonable explanation
of what we're trying to do.
This is how terse the code is.
The tooling and machine
learning is really, really hard.
We're doing it better.
We're making it more simple.
The fact that it isn't scribbled
on a napkin or a whiteboard
and erased as soon as
the data scientists
leave the room is a big step
forward for the marketplace,
and we're going to continue
to improve the experience.
Let me get to the money
and the power here.
Use Cloud ML because it
takes a long time to train.
Let me skip right
to the money shot.
It's 123 hours to do
what I just explained
on roughly a developer
workstation class machine.
Come back in five days
and you get your answer.
and get your answer
and then begin iteration.
Wait another five days or
argue about it for three days
and then come back
in another five days.
Welcome to the machine
scientist's nightmare.
That's the state
of the art today.
By just changing
one line, you say,
I want to run it on
premium instance.
I don't configure anymore
machines, come back
in three hours.
And if you want to go more,
we can go more if you'd like.
Don't contact me
directly, we have people.
So now you enter into
the interesting space
of it's OK but not great.
The accuracy isn't what I want.
It's 60%, and I'm not
going to make a business
decision on 60%.
If only there were a wand
with some magic pixie dust in.
Well, it's not quite
magic pixie dust.
It's a lot of PhD sweat and
tears that gone into it,
but Hypertune allows you
to automatically tune
the aspects for the
model that may not
be learning or asymptotic
towards the result
that you're asking for the
model to predict against.
So through one simple
change of code--
it literally is
one line of code,
and if Rob can find it
quickly-- There we go.
Jobs trainer task.
Off you go, and
you get the machine
now spinning up multiple
multiple instances,
running multiple
experiments at once,
picking which one is maximizing
towards the prediction
that you want, and
rendering an answer.
So there is what you
need to do if you're
a data scientist with Cloud ML.
I encourage you to compare
it to what your current data
scientists get to use.
It's a lot different
proposition.
So this is if you
create your own.
Let's see what someone
actually created themselves.
So we have a used car
customer in Japan,
and what they're trying to do--
and this is a real example.
This is the model they
created, not Google.
They allowed us
to demo for them--
is they want to better
understand what they just
bought at auction or what
they would like to put
on sale at auction in Japan.
So we have a whole series
of images to the side.
Imagine I'm a used car salesman.
I took a bunch of
pictures of the vehicle,
and I just would like it
to go up on the auction
site immediately without me
tediously identifying what
the image was, front and
rear, with the model was,
getting it wrong.
So let me go ahead and
select all of my camera reel.
I'm going to drop it directly
onto the application.
Let me minimize.
And you'll see these
bits are actually
going to a hosted instance
in our new Tokyo data center,
but you see it actually
beginning to do some analysis.
This takes about 30 seconds.
And I've been
threatened with my life
if I go too long, so let
me flip over the answer
that you'd see in 30 seconds.
We're 89% sure-- we
being the used car
company-- this is a 2012
Toyota Land Cruiser Pareto.
That's not available
in the US, by the way.
It's anywhere from $39,000
to $43,000 currently
at auction because we're
combining other data sources
in the background.
And the images
have been correctly
identified-- right side, left
side, quarter panel, interior,
stick shift, control
panel, you get the idea.
Drastically changing
the experience,
but it's not machine
learning in your face.
So you can train
your own models using
pretty simple tools
that Google Skill,
and I hope you find
that interesting.
Thank you.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you, Rob.
So it's really great.
You can see that it actually
has a company dealing with very
physical objects like cars.
You can make use of much
more data with Cloud ML.
This graph here
shows the adoption
of machine learning at Google.
And as people discover the power
and as the tools get better,
you can really
see usage explode.
So today, it's used in pretty
much every Google application.
And our goal with Cloud
ML is that the adoption
rate in your company of machine
learning looks like this.
Because tools are getting
easier and more powerful to use.
Let's actually look
at another example--
a real world example
of one of our customers
using cloud machine learning.
And so please, welcome
Mathias Ortner from Airbus.
Mathias.
So for a little
bit of background,
Mathias has been working on
image analysis for the past 15
years for Airbus-- company
with 30,000 employees,
13 billion euros of revenue,
working in all kinds of areas
in air and space.
But today, we're talking
about satellite imagery--
commercial satellite imagery.
So Mathias, tell us a
little bit about the problem
that you were facing.
MATHIAS ORTNER: Well, basically
we are selling satellite images
and we want to
provide our customers
with high-quality images.
And that means we don't want
to have clouds within the image
because if you have
clouds, the bottom is
hiding because we're
looking from the sky--
well, from space.
And as a customer, I won't
pay for such an image.
So what we're doing is we're
trying to figure out in the end
if we have clouds within
each image we are selling.
So OK, here I have an example.
Maybe you can try to guess--
well, you have the solution,
but you can see sometimes is
kind of hard to distinguish
clouds from the sky.
URS HOLZLE: That's right.
So the image actually shows
how difficult this is.
This shows a bunch of mountains.
Mostly white is snow, but
actually in the upper right,
if you look really closely,
it's not snow, it's clouds.
So that actually sounds
like an interesting problem.
I assume Airbus has been
working this for a while.
Is this an easy problem
or a hard problem?
MATHIAS ORTNER: That's a point.
Actually, we've been working
on that for 20 years.
And we try to be very
smart, I have to say.
No automatic solution has
proven to be reliable enough.
And every day, we have human
operators drawing cloud masks
on every single image we
download from our satellites.
And it's a lot, because
we are downloading
thousands of images every day.
So that's what brought us
to use machine learning
and try to figure
out what can be done
with these new technologies.
URS HOLZLE: That's
a pretty big job.
If you look at
just this picture,
it will take you a while to be
accurate about what's a cloud.
And then just imagine
thousands of pictures.
So I could see how you
want to have an improvement
and why you tried
cloud machine learning.
Well, did it work for you?
MATHIAS ORTNER: Well, I
started to use machine learning
five years ago, and we had some
success on several problems.
When you started to use
cloud machine learning
on this specific topic,
beginning with this,
we had tremendous results.
URS HOLZLE: Can you
give us some numbers?
MATHIAS ORTNER: Yeah, sure.
Well our previous
automatic solution
had an error rate around 11%.
So that's a lot,
and that's why we
need these human operators to
draw cloud masks on the images.
And we achieved a 3% error
rate using TensorFlow and Cloud
ML, which is much better.
We now have a solution
for our problem.
This is the new situation.
And I think what is
most impressive for us
and for everybody in this room,
it took us only three months
to reach this point, which
is much faster than what
we used to have in
previous developments.
That's I think very impressive.
URS HOLZLE: That is
really impressive.
Yes.
How was your experience
with Google overall?
Not just Cloud ML, but
Google Cloud per se?
MATHIAS ORTNER: Well,
I'm very positive.
We're very reactive.
Both commercial
and technical teams
were really helping
me on our teams
to just get focused
on what we have to do
in the core of our business.
We had a great experience.
People were very
dedicated, hard workers.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you.
So what's next for
you and for Airbus?
MATHIAS ORTNER:
Well, first of all,
we are now investigating how
to put this into production.
That's the first step.
And now we have seen that
you can solve all problems.
We have plenty of ideas.
We want to bring added
value to our customers.
And we will for sure use machine
learning for several products
in the coming years.
URS HOLZLE: OK, so
you're probably-- I
mean, clearly it was
successful for you.
And you've started using
the alpha versions.
So you're few months
ahead of everyone else who
can try the beta today.
If there's one or two things
that you would give us advice
to our audience,
what would you pick?
MATHIAS ORTNER: Well, I
think something really new
is happening now.
I mean, this problem, I've been
working on like six years ago,
three years ago.
And we couldn't
find any solution.
No machine learning
can solve problems
that couldn't be solved before.
That's the first point.
And I think it's not
only about bringing
new services or new stuff, it's
also about our day-to-day job.
Our engineering work is changing
and going further quickly.
URS HOLZLE: Thank you very much.
That's really amazing.
Congratulations.
So I just want to recap, because
it's really an amazing story.
There's a hard
problem-- very clearly.
It would be hard
for any one of us
to go and pick clouds
on these images.
They've been working on it
for literally two decades.
And in three months,
with our alpha version,
Mathias was able to beat the
existing system by a factor
of four in error rate.
That's truly amazing.
And I actually want to leave
you with one more thought,
because those of you old enough
to remember might remember that
about 10 years ago, Netflix
had a competition with a $ 1
million prize to
researchers out there.
Anyone could
participate to predict
what movies you're going to
like based on a set of existing
movie ratings.
And the best
researchers-- hundreds
of teams across the world--
competed in that competition.
And after three years, someone
won the $1 million prize.
And the amazing thing is that
today with Google Cloud ML,
in one day, you can
build a model that
would be competitive
in that competition.
And I bet that in under
a month, you could
build something that would win.
So that is how much
the field has changed.
Just 10 years ago-- less
than 10 years ago-- only
the world's best experts
struggling for three years
could do something.
And today, actually
you have a fair chance
to meet or beat these
results because the tools
have gotten so much better.
So if you've been thinking
about machine learning,
now is really a good time
to start trying it out.
So now, let me just
recap a little bit what
we talked about today.
I hope I can convince
you that we're
building a different
kind of cloud, one that's
really oriented around
making it much easier to use
all of the capabilities.
Moving away from
virtualized hardware
to scalable services,
scalable data.
And I hope I've shown you
that with the new version
of BigQuery, scalable
data got even easier.
You have a data
warehouse in a cloud,
zero admin, infinitely
scalable, at a superb price
and with superb
performance, and your choice
of whether you want to have
variable pricing or fixed
price.
And then beyond that, I hope
that Mathias just convinced
you, or the other demos, that
machine learning really today
is within reach
for most companies.
If you use Google Cloud ML, even
in its beta version-- in fact,
even in its alpha version-- it
can deliver incredible value
to you.
And obviously, we're spending
an enormous amount of time
on making these tools and
the infrastructure behind it
better every single day.
So we only will get
easier in the future.
Now, that's the true power
of this next generation cloud
because you can focus on
insights, on creating value
from your data, not on
orchestrating and administering
all that stuff.